helicopters flying very low fire
missiles on an oil installation inside
russia before a massive explosion
ukraine refuses to confirm or deny it
was behind this
but unless this is russia staging an
attack on itself
it's the first ukrainian air assault on
russia beyond its borders a major
development in this war either way a
huge amount of russian oil went up in
smoke
but it's not just in the air on the
ground ukraine's been on the offensive
too
russian troops are pulling back around
kiev and chernahiv not just near pin
where skye filmed yesterday but in a
number of villages and suburbs retaken
by ukrainian forces in the last 24 hours
the fortunes of war ebb and flow and
across ukraine cities will be bracing
themselves for potential russian
reprisals and counter-attacks but more
than five weeks into this war russia
appears to be on the back foot at least
for now
ukrainians are finding more and more
evidence of war crimes as they move into
areas deserted by russia
while its foreign minister was again
turning reality on its head
all the standards of decency and all the
norms of international law all the
values implemented by the west within
its model of globalization all this was
violated by the west itself
but a red cross attempt to evacuate
civilians from the perceived city had to
turn back because it says conditions
made it impossible to proceed
while europeans worry about the impact
of war on energy bills an uncompromising
message from the mayor of la viv to the
west to get real and accept the cost of
standing up to a dictator
i think democratic countries must
totally head off russia
russia it is today nazi country money
or freedom
you must make choice
if
choice
money
you lost freedom
i choice freedom
a rallying cry from one ukrainian on the
day his country appears to have opened a
new chapter in its fight for freedom
dominic waghorn sky news lev